bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver sur public sénat pour la suite
de l'examen du projet de loi très
controversée sur le renseignement
les sénateurs sont en plein dans
l'examen des articles ils ont adopté le
très controversé article 3 sur les
techniques de renseignement mais en le
modifiant très substantiellement l'usagé
de cette technique sera donc limitée
dans le temps
trente jours au lieu de deux mois pour
la captation de données stockées dans un
ordinateur personnel
et puis lorsque la surveillance se fait
sans la vie sans la conformité avec la
fameuse commission de contrôle
le conseil d'état sera immédiatement
saisi voilà on découvre tout de suite
dans l'hémicycle l'examen de cet article
la parole est à madame benbassa pour
l'amendement 105
merci monsieur le président est la
sonorisation comme vous le savez est une
technique extrêmement attentatoires aux
libertés individuelles notamment par son
caractère totalement non discriminant
des personnes surveillées
il importe de fixer une limitation du
nombre de sonorisation autorisé dans les
mêmes conditions que les limitations
apportées pour les interceptions de
sécurité notamment pour connaître leur
nombre comme la souris l'a souligné jean
marie delarue président de la scène
c'est yes je cite on dit qu'on va
pouvoir sonorisé les appartements est ce
que ces vins est ce que ces deux sens
est ce que ces 2000 est ce que ces vingt
mille par an il faut que le gouvernement
souhaite un peu précis sur ses
intentions
une société où il ya 200 appartements
sonorisée on peut penser que c'est pour
les criminels et les terroristes
une société où il y en a 200 milles
c'est l'avis des autres vis avec
majuscule est fan des citations
merci merci mme asha collègues
l'amendement 169 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
oui cet amendement monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vise
à préserver l'hypothèse dans laquelle le
lieu faisant l'objet de l'intrusion est
désigné par référence aux personnes
faisant l'objet de la demande prévue à
l'article l 221 tiré deux des cadres de
la sécurité intérieure en 76 monsieur le
ministre
alors cet amendement est un amendement
qu'est le gouvernement tient qui est
important pour l'équilibré du texte il
convient vous l'avez souhaité pour un
très grand nombre d'entre vous de
renforcer les garanties afférentes à
l'introduction dans un lieu à usage
d'habitation en exigeant la saisine
immédiate du conseil d'état lorsque
l'introduction a été autorisé à prix
défavorable après avis défavorable de la
commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement
sauf en matière de terrorisme cette
saisine suspend l'exécution de
l'intrusion ainsi autorisé c'est donc
une garantie très forte que le
gouvernement se propose d'apporter par
cet amendement à la question des
libertés individuelles dont vous avez
parlé les uns et les autres
merci monsieur le ministre l'amendement
196 monsieur le président bah au nom de
la commission
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues je salue cet amendement du
gouvernement que vient de présenter deux
ministres de l'intérieur en ce que il
prévoit dans des cas tout à fait
exceptionnel l'obligation que le conseil
d'état se prononce parce qu'il s'agit
d'une décision lourde de conséquences et
elle a fait l'objet d'un avis
défavorable de la commission nationale
de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement un cas tout à fait
exceptionnelle où le conseil d'état
serait en quelque sorte obligatoirement
saisie on n'aurait pas le droit de ne
pas le saisir
mais qui va le saisir
et sur ce point j'ai un désaccord la
commission des lois a désaccord avec le
choix qui est proposée par le
gouvernement
car le gouvernement propose au premier
ministre une forme de schizophrénie d'un
côté il prend une autorisation pour
mettre en oeuvre une technique très
intrusive et de l'autre côté il saisit
le conseil d'état pour qu'il annule
l'utilisation de cette technique
je crois que ça n'est véritablement pas
possible alors j'entends bien
l'analogique il petit avoir quand un
président de la république dit nous
adoptons en conseil des ministres un
texte et je défèrerait ce texte à
l'issue de la discussion parlementaire
devant le conseil constitutionnel
mais cette analogie à ses limites car en
l'occurrence le conseil constitutionnel
et il n'est nul besoin de le saisir de
moyens d'annulation d'un texte il a
lui-même a examiné l'ensemble de la
constitutionnalité de ce texte et donc
il n'a pas été prévu par la constitution
ni par la loi organique n'est par aucun
autre texte que quand on saisit le
conseil constitutionnel il faut lui
demander impérativement d'annuler le
texte dont il est saisi
tandis que le code des juridictions
administratives jusqu'à présent prévoit
bien que quand on saisit le conseil
d'état
on le saisit d'une demande d'annulation
ou alors d'une demande de réparation
d'un préjudice qui aurait été causé par
une un acte de l'administration je ne
vois pas comment le premier ministre
peut demander l'annulation d'une
autorisation le jour même où il l'a
délivré sur l'avis défavorable de la
commission mais je souscris à
l'intention de l'amendement du
gouvernement qui est excellente et qui
consiste à dire
j'offre la garantie à tous nos
concitoyens que quand il s'agit de
une technique de renseignements très
intrusive et qu'elle a été décidé malgré
l'avis défavorable de la commission le
conseil d'état dans ce cas sera saisi et
je propose simplement que ce soit le
président de la commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
qui lui aura quelques raisons de pouvoir
argumenter dans le sens de l'annulation
ce que n'aura pas le premier ministre
qui saisissent le conseil d'état dans
les mêmes délais d'ailleurs que le
premier ministre l'aurait fait j'ai
précisé l'amendement pour que on peut
toujours prévoir le cas
d'indisponibilité absolu du président de
la commission et pour que le délai soit
retenue il faut que le faire le jour
même
j'ai précisé que à défaut du président
se serait l'un des membres de la
commission
parmi ceux qui ont le pouvoir de donner
un avis tout seul qui saisirait le
président pardon qu'ils saisiraient le
conseil d'état de la demande
d'annulation de la décision que le
premier ministre
par hypothèse aura prise voilà le sens
de ce sous-amendement je m'inscris bien
dans la démarche du gouvernement mais je
précise que c'est pas le premier
ministre qui saisit mais le président de
la commission ou là des membres de la
commission ayant qualité pour le faire
merci monsieur le président quel est
maintenant l'avis de la commission sur
les différents amendements et on va
commencer par l'amendement numéro 61
sur le 61 la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur le centquatre
elle a également émis un avis
défavorable sur le 17
rectifiez quater est là aussi il n'a pas
été défendu sur le 83 présentée par
monsieur y est elle a émis un avis
favorable c'est donc le même avis qui
était rendu pour le 160 rectifié qui est
identique présenté par monsieur sueur et
plusieurs de nos autres collègues sur le
66 rectifié bis sans revenir sur les
problèmes de rédaction qu'il comporte et
d'imputation à l'alinéa 11 de l'article
3 qui n'est pas correct du point de vue
logistique me dit on la vie est
également défavorable car il est très
difficile que les dispositifs mis en
oeuvre pour la captation de données
informatiques puisse comporter les
distinctions que matériellement
l'amendement 66 rectifié bis implique
ensuite l'amendement 21 rectifié terre
de monsieur le président y est et d'un
grand nombre de ses collègues apparu
extrêmement intéressant à la commission
qu'il a retenus en lui donnant l avis
favorable
monsieur le comte a présenté un
amendement numéro 40 pour réduire à un
mois la durée de l'autorisation de mise
en oeuvre de la technique de captation
de données informatiques
il a aussi cet amendement soumis le
renouvellement une autorisation du juge
judiciaire alors s'agissant de ce
dernier point il est contraire à la
constitution puisque le juge judiciaire
doit s'occuper de répression de
sanctions pénales et pas de
l'appréciation de la légalité des
mesures de police administrative dans
tant d'autres aspects de cet amendement
il est sur le délai partiellement
satisfait si les amendements 83 et 160
auquel la commission aura donné un avis
favorable sont adoptées par notre
assemblée
madame benbassa dans son amendement 105
a souhaité contingenté le nombre de
sonorisation la vie a été défavorable
parce que cette mesure risque de
contraintes fortement l'activité des
services alors même que des besoins
essentiels pourraient se faire sentir
pour la protection des intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ou la lutte
contre le terrorisme par exemple
l'amendement 169 du gouvernement a fait
l'objet d'un avis défavorable
et enfin j'ai déjà dit je crois que la
commission avait donné un avis favorable
aux 76 du gouvernement pourvu que son
amendement numéro 196 soit adopté merci
monsieur le rapporteur
tel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre un oui je me permets de
poser une question rapporteur qui donne
un avis défavorable sur l'amendement 169
du gouvernement sans en expliquer les
raisons
est-ce que je peux monsieur le
rapporteur voir les raisons pour
lesquelles vous est défavorable à cet
amendement
monsieur le président pouvez-vous
répondre monsieur le ministre mais bien
sûr monsieur le ministre cet amendement
comme vous l'avez justement expliqué à
pour objet de préciser que lorsque la
demande d'introduction dans un lieu
privé est faite sans que le service
demandeur le connaisse précisément le
lieu la demande peut être faite en se
référant simplement à la personne qui
est visé par la mesure
en application du droit commun toutefois
cette précision semble inutile dans la
mesure où les règles définies à
l'article
elle lui 150 3-3 s'ajoutent à celles
définies par les dispositions de droit
commun de l'article elle lui 121-2 et ne
s'excluent pas donc ces dispositions
sont applicables par principe comme
l'est la disposition de cet article
selon laquelle quand le lieu n'est pas
précisément connues la demande fait
référence à la personne et enfin le
texte de l'article l
850 3-3 créer une obligation de moyens
en imposant de fournir je le cite toute
indication permettant d'identifier le
lieu fin de citation c'est à dire de
fournir les informations disponibles qui
peuvent être très réduite voire
inexistantes aussi monsieur mais nice
est un motif en réalité de pure
légistique qui a conduit la commission
des lois a donné cet avis défavorable
mais certainement pas un motif de fonds
merci monsieur le président n'a par
l'état monsieur le ministre pour l'avis
du gouvernement sur l'ensemble des
amendements
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
président philippe bas contenu des
explications que vous venez donner et de
l'interprétation que vous n'êtes
développer et qui sera au compte rendu
de nos débats mois je retire cet
amendement jeu l'excèdent volontiers au
raisonnement qui est celui du rapporteur
dès lors que les motifs pour lesquels et
ils s'opposent à cet amendement ne
compromettent pas la bonne
interprétation du texte qui convient au
gouvernement donc je le dis pour pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de problème sur ce
point
l'ensemble des amendements qui ont été
présentés porte sur les techniques les
plus intrusive qui sont prévues par le
projet de loi à savoir les mesures de
sonorisation de captation d'imagés de
données informatiques pouvant
s'accompagner de l'introduction dans un
lieu privé d'habitation ou d'un système
de traitement de données d'informations
et l'ensemble des amendements sont des
amendements qui sont motivés par des
interrogations des questions qui
résultent de craintes concernant les
effets que peuvent avoir ces techniques
sur les libertés individuelles et moi je
comprends parfaitement
ces amendements et bien qu étant
défavorables à leurs contenus
je me dois d'expliquer précisément les
raisons pour lesquelles je le suis et je
voudrais rappeler que le régime
applicable aux mesures qui font l'objet
ses amendements est un régime
particulièrement encadrée est beaucoup
plus exigeant que celui qui prévaut pour
les autres mesures envisagées par le
projet de loi
ainsi la mise en oeuvre des techniques
mentionnées au chapitre iii et iv est
strictement encadrée par une procédure
qui permet un contrôle de la légalité de
la proportionnalité de la mesure une
autorisation ne pourra délivrer que si
la finalité invoquée par le service à
l'origine de la demande est parfaitement
en adéquation avec les missions qui sont
les siennes et s'il n'existe aucune
alternative possible pour obtenir des
renseignements
deuxièmement l'autorisation est limitée
à deux mois contre quatre mois pour
toutes les autres techniques
troisièmement lorsqu'elle s'accompagne
de l'introduction dans un lieu privé
d'habitation ou un véhicule ou vis des
professions protégées
elle nécessite un avis express de la
scène c'était en formation collégiale
sans que les procédures d'urgence soit
applicable
assis sur ce point sauf dans certains
cas très particulier pour les
professions protégées et l'autorisation
est alors limitée à un mois
quatrièmement il ne vous a pas échappé
que le gouvernement est soucieux
d'apporter les garanties supplémentaires
en la matière
qu'il a déposé un amendement 76 qui
prévoit la saisine automatique du
conseil d'état en cas de volonté du
premier ministre de passer outre l'avis
de la scène ctr en cas de techniques
s'accompagnant d'une intrusion dans un
lieu privilégié d'habitation dans cette
hypothèse est sauf en matière de
terrorisme
l'autorisation est bien entendu suspendu
dans l'attenté de la décision de la
haute juridiction
à cet égard j'ai entendu les remarques
du président philippe bas concernant la
volonté de voir le gouvernement
demandez aux prémices lui-même de saisir
la scène c'était considéré que cela
engendre une forme de schizophrénie je
ne le crois pas d'abord parce que la cnc
terre peut se saisir elle-même avoir
l'accès à la totalité des éléments
ensuite parce que le fait que le premier
ministre la saisissent permettra
simplement à l'autorité juridictionnelle
à savoir le conseil d'état d'examiner la
totalité des sujets comme il pourrait le
faire par lui-même est en réalité les
choses sont assez neutre mais bon ça n'a
pas d'importance
et moi je ne me battrais pas sur ce
sujet ce qui compte c'est que le conseil
d'état soit saisi
vous souhaitez qu'il le soit autrement
nous avons une autre approche de ce
sujet mais à un moment donné il faut
faire des choix et ce qui compte c'est
qu'ils soient saisis donc sur le
sous-amendement que vous présentez le
gouvernement s'en remettre à la sagesse
du sénat et nous souhaitons en réalité
que la disposition qui permet de
conforter et garantis soit adopté le res
peut faire l'objet d'un débat entre nous
mais il n'est pas mon avis déterminant
au regard de l'objectif que poursuit
gouvernement présentant son amendement
le dispositif que nous proposons est
donc de nature à porter un certain
nombre de garanties qui selon nous ne
justifie pas les amendements proposés
qui vise à limiter les besoins
opérationnels des services
d'une part ces événements que l'on
évoquerait la restriction de l'usagé de
ces techniques au seul cadre judiciaire
dès lors que le conseil constitutionnel
lui-même admet que les techniques de
renseignement puissent être inspirée de
celle mise en oeuvre en police
judiciaire interceptions de sécurité
géolocalisation pourvu qu'elles soient
mises en oeuvre de manière adaptée et
proportionnée avec des garanties claires
et encadré
or tel est bien le cas comme je les ai
exposés précédemment
de même ces mesures ne saurait être
limitée à certaines seulement des
finalités prévu par la loi au risque de
nuire à l'efficacité des services
opérationnels et de ne pouvoir opérer
une hiérarchisation entre les différents
intérêts poursuivi c'est la raison pour
laquelle je ne suis pas favorable à
l'amendement présenté par madame
kuperman parce que ne paraît pas être
conforme à l'état du droit ce qui est
dit dans cet amendement ne correspond
pas l'état de droit est défavorable
également à l'amendement de madame
benbassa il n'apparaît pas davantage
opportun de limiter à un mois la durée
de ces autorisations déjà limitée par
rapport au droit commun applicable aux
autres techniques laquelle est de 4 mois
avec possibilité de renouvellement de
même durée comme je voulais 10 pour ses
techniques la durée est portée à deux
mois et deux mois pour chaque
renouvellement et un mois lorsqu'elle
implique une intrusion dans un véhicule
ou d'homicide
il s'agit déjà de durée particulièrement
réduite qui ne saurait l'être davantage
sauf à décider de priver les services de
toute efficacité
auquel cas c'est la technique elle-même
à laquelle il faudra il faudrait
renoncer par suite sauf a multiplié les
demandes d'autorisation qui le plus
souvent ne rompt pas encore été mises en
oeuvre ou n'auront pas produit dans ces
faits il est souhaitable je leur ai dit
de s'en tenir aux durs est actuellement
prévue par le projet de loi je ne suis
donc pas favorable à l'amendement de
monsieur liesse et de monsieur sueur
pour une raison identique
il n'est pas souhaitable de contingenter
ce type de mesures dont le nombre sera
par définition restreint compte tenu de
l'année
ficultés de les mettre en oeuvre
puisqu'elle nécessite une intervention
humaine et je reste on l'a à la
préoccupation monsieur c'est un thomas
durée que vous avez exprimées dans votre
intervention
en tout état de cause de telles
techniques sont sans commune mesure avec
les interceptions de sécurité qui
peuvent être opérés à distance et leur
nom je le dis très clairement dans le
sénat sera nécessairement limités sans
qu'il y ait besoin de prévoir un
contingentement pour des raisons qui
sont consubstantiels à la nature de ses
opérations
de même la suppression de la possibilité
de mettre en oeuvre des techniques à
l'encontre des professions protégées ne
paraît pas davantage opportune
s'agissant de la protection de certaines
professions
le texte du gouvernement a été très
substantiellement enrichi à l'issue des
débats devant l'assemblée nationale et
devant la commission des lois de votre
assemblée en ce domaine
je pense que nous sommes arrivés
désormais à un équilibre je rappelle que
l'article
elle lui 51-5-2 prévoit lorsque la
demande de mise en oeuvre d'une
technique concernant parlementaires à
magistrat et un avocat ou un journaliste
que la commission doit se réunir dans sa
formation plénière pour rendre son avis
qu'elle est informée des modalités
d'exécution des autorisations qu'elle
délivre et que les transcriptions des
renseignements ainsi collectés lui sont
transmises en outre la procédure
d'urgence n'est pas applicable à ces
professions je pense que ces
dispositions garantissant conciliation
nécessaire entre le respect du secret
attaché à certaines professions et la
défense et la promotion des intérêts
publics compris dans les finalités du
renseignement de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs le premier ministre raffarin
a fait ya une intervention qui a été
extrêmement limpides quant au risque qui
pouvait s'attacher à rompre la rupture
de cet équilibre et je partage tout à
fait l'intervention qu'il a pu faire
aller au delà et interdire la mise en
oeuvre de ces techniques de
renseignement dans les cabinets locaux
professionnels ne permettrait plus de
garantir cette conciliation et apparaît
très disproportionnée car elle pourrait
créer une sorte de sanctuaire
particulièrement attractifs comme vous
l'avez souligné
pour les personnes souhaitant porter
atteinte aux intérêts de notre pays
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur ce
point enfin s'agissant de l'amendement
de monsieur m'a viré visant à soumettre
au principe de prévisibilité à une
captation de son ou de données il est
techniquement impraticable aujourd'hui
faute pour les dispositifs actuellement
utilisé par les services de
renseignement d'être capable de procéder
à un tri pendant la collecte de ces
données cette opération ne peut
s'effectuer qu'à postériori c'est
pourquoi je suis également défavorable à
cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre dont je vais
mettre aux voix
l'amendement 61 qui est pour cet
amendement qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté je vais
mettre voix l'amendement 104 de madame
benbassa qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 83
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement et
l'amendement identique 160 rectifié qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement et les amendements sont
adoptés
je me vois l'amendement 66 rectifié bis
avait deux amies des pas voir monsieur
malgré vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur je veux
bien que vous soyez défavorablement mon
amendement mais n'utilisait pas
l'argument de l'impossibilité technique
c'est tellement simple il suffit pour
réaliser ce que souhaitent mon
amendement que le dispositif
d'interception se coupe automatiquement
au moment où la communication avec
l'extérieur est coupée c'est à dire qu'à
un étudiant en informatique de première
année peut faire le code de cette de
cette procédure et que quand vous ne
profitez pas du fait tu nous sommes pas
tous des spécialistes en informatique
couleurs pour dire que c'est plus
tactique pas impossible trouver un autre
argument il est possible avec de la
façon la plus simple de couper la
surveillance au moment où la
communication est coupée
voilà c'est une manoeuvre tellement
simple que je voudrais que vous trouviez
d'autres arguments
merci mon cher collègue dont monsieur le
président vous avez la parole mes chers
collègues ce qui est écrit dans votre
abonnement
ce n'est pas que aux coupes
l'enregistrement
quand il y a une conversation qui sort
du lieu privé c'est exactement le
contraire vous avez écrit les
dispositifs techniques utilisés à cette
fin garantissent que les seules
informations captées sont celles
effectivement échangés lors d'une
conversation sortant du lieu privé et
vous venez de nous dire à l'instant que
il y avait des dispositifs à la portée
de n'importe quel étudiant de première
année qui consistait à permettre que
quand il ya une conversation sortant ton
couple dispositif est alors je n'y
comprends plus rien
excusez moi mais voilà je voulais juste
dire ça et monsieur le président dont si
vous verte et je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 66 rectifié bis qui fait
l'objet de deux avis défavorables qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement 21 à rectifier
terre avec l'avis favorable de la
commission est défavorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui contre
l'amendement est adopté l'amendement 40
tombe
nous passons à l'amendement 105 de
madame benbassa avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté et nous arrivons au
sous-amendement 196 présent rectifiée
présentée par le président monsieur
président de la commission qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient de soul man
sous amendement est adopté et je me vois
l'amendement du gouvernement de 916
ainsi sous-amendé qui est pour et qui
est contre
il s'abstient l'amendement est adopté je
vais me retrouve wal article 3
y at il des explications de vote vous
avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci la ministre mes chers collègues je
me rappelle très certainement par
rapport à la question que j'ai posée
hier au moment de voter l'article 2 et
je reposerai la même question au moment
de voter cet article 3 puisque à travers
ces deux articles nous permettons le
déploiement d'un certain nombre
nouvelle technique qui nécessiteront
forcément un investissement pour
l'acquisition de l'ensemble des
dispositifs que nous venons de valider
et qui nécessiteront également puisque
si nous les autorisons c'est bien pour
qu'il puisse être utilisé un certain
nombre de ressources humaines et donc de
personnes pour pouvoir traiter
efficacement l'information et éviter la
surveillance généralisée ciblées et
pouvoir bien évidemment à travers ces
milliers de données qui pourront ainsi
être captées par les différents
dispositifs que nous avons évoquées
depuis hier hier après midi et bien
pouvoir les analyser
puisque je crois que l'ensemble des
spécialistes y compris du renseignement
et cela avait été reconnue suite aux
malheureux et aux événements tragiques
du mois de janvier dans notre pays avait
noté la difficulté d'anticipation au vu
de la de l'immense masse de données et
donc la nécessaire capacité à savoir et
pouvoir mieux les analyses et donc
certainement des méthodes de travail à
faire évoluer pour les rendre plus
performantes mais aussi une donnée en
termes de disponibilité humaine et donc
je vous repose monsieur le ministre mamy
cela même question qui hier soir
peut-on avoir une impact du coût que
cela représente puisque nous n'avons pas
vu dans l'étude d'impact tels que fait
par le gouvernement initialement
merci ma chère collègue monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole oui madame
la sénatrice le premier ministre et
moi-même avons répondu à plusieurs
reprises façon extrêmement précise à
cette question est donc le faire des
recherches de manière à ce que vous ayez
tous les éléments dont vous avez besoin
le premie dans son discours et
j'ai répondu à plusieurs questions au
gouvernement sur ce sujet dans votre
assemblée comme à l'assemblée nationale
a pris des dispositions dès le mois de
janvier pour assurer le financement de
l'ensemble des mesures de lutte contre
le terrorisme dont celle dont nous
parlons et qui concerne les moyens
alloués aux services de renseignements
pour ce qui concerne les moyens humains
et je sais à quel point votre groupe est
attaché à ce que les services et des
moyens de fonctionner nous avons pris la
décision depuis le début du quinquennat
d'augmenter de 432 les effectifs de la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure considérant qu'aux termes des
événements de janvier
cet effort devait être conforté il a été
décidé pour le ministère de l'intérieur
de créer sur la période 2015 2017 1500
emplois supplémentaires qui se
répartiront de la manière suivante 500
emplois supplémentaires pour la
direction centrale du renseignement
territoriale qui se décomposeront eux
mêmes de la manière suivante 150 emplois
pour la gendarmerie nationale pour ses
services de renseignements intérieurs et
250 pour les services et 350 pour les
services de la police nationale 500
emplois en plus des 432 pour la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure les 400 autres emplois seront
répartis entre les différents services
du ministère de l'intérieur la direction
centrale de la police de l'air et des
frontières
la service de protection des
personnalités
la direction centrale de la police
judiciaire dans son service 6 lutte
contre la cybercriminalité de manière à
ce que nous puissions faire face à tout
ce dont nous parlons et qui concerne la
lutte contre le terrorisme
par ailleurs nous avons besoin de
crédits dits orthez 2 il a été décidé
d'allouer une enveloppe pour la même
période de 233 millions d'euros sur 7
233 millions d'euros 98 millions d'euros
sont d'ores et déjà mobilisés pour 2015
et c'est 233 millions d'euros serviront
à quoi à l'équipement numérique des
services à la modernisation des
infrastructures
informatique du ministère de l'intérieur
on avait parlé au moment du retour des
trois jihadistes de turquie des
défaillances du système khéops parce que
ce système n'avait pas été modernisé
depuis 15 ans nous investissons
massivement dans la modernisation de ses
systèmes informatiques nous décidons
d'acquérir des véhicules et des moyens
dont le service du renseignement
territoriales a besoin qu'ils sont des
moyens aussi élémentaires que des
appareils photos et autres voilà donc
voilà très précisément ce que nous
faisons et c'est un effort considérable
qui est destiné à faire en sorte que nos
services et les moyens de travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
merci monsieur le ministre dont je mets
aux voix l'article 3 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient
l'article 3 est adopté nous revenons
cours normal de la discussion des
articles et j'appelle en discussion
l'amendement numéro 92 au sein de
l'article 1er qui est présenté par
madame benbassa
amendement 92
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement vise à préciser que le
recours aux techniques de recueil de
l'enseignement envisagée par le présent
texte n'est possible que lorsque les
renseignements ne peuvent être
recueillis par un autre moyen légalement
autorisés et du fait de leur caractère
particulièrement attentatoires aux
libertés individuelles et la à la vie
privée les techniques mentionnés ici ne
doivent pouvoir être employé qu'en
l'absence de toute autre possibilité
légale
nous considérons que ce principe doit
absolument être affirmée dans la loi ce
qui n'est pas le cas
merci leurs collègues quel est l'avis de
la commission
mais chut le rapporteur il est
défavorable nous sommes inscrits dans
une autre logique qui me paraît plus
protectrice encore elle consiste à faire
en sorte qu'ils aient toutes les
garanties pour que les mesures prises
soient strictement proportionnées aux
fins poursuivies de sorte que jamais une
mesure de l'utilisation d'une technique
de renseignement ne pourra être reconnu
comme légale si elle est
disproportionnée aux fins poursuivies
si nous devions à chaque fois qu'il y à
une demande d'autorisation statuer sur
le point de savoir s'il n'y a pas de
meilleur moyen pour obtenir les mêmes
enseignements ce serait rendre
impossible la tâche de la commission de
contrôle qui aurait en quelque sorte à
se substituer à l'appréciation de
l'opportunité de recourir à une
technique plutôt qu'à une autre dans
toute la gamme des techniques possibles
ce qui nous apporte ce n'est pas que
l'administration ait choisi une
technique par rapport à une autre c'est
que la technique choisie soit utilisé
dans des conditions légales et à partir
du moment où on aura fixé toutes les
garanties pour que ce soit le cas il n'y
a strictement aucune raison de devoir
situé l'appréciation de la commission
puis celle du premier ministre puis
celle du conseil d'état dans une sorte
de comparaison entre les techniques nous
avons déjà d'ailleurs eu le même débat
hier l'avis de la commission a déjà été
défavorable
le sénat a voté en suivant la commission
donc ça n'est que la confirmation que je
vous demande du vote que vous avez émis
hier et dans quel est l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur ministre avec
grand regret je ne suis pas favorable à
cet amendement mais pour des raisons que
madame benbassa va va comprendre et
auxquels j'en suis convaincue elle va
adhérer c'est parce que cet amendement
est moins protecteur pour le citoyen que
ne l'est le texte du gouvernement parce
que ce qui garantit la protection pour
le citoyen d'ailleurs fille bas vient de
l'exprimer à l'insensé le principe de
proportionnalité
c'est ça le principe fort du texte c'est
le principe de proportionnalité qui
impose à l'administration à chaque fois
qu'elle mobilise une technique de
renseignement d'être en situation
d'apporter la démonstration que la
technique utilisée par l'administration
et proportionnées aux finalités pour
lesquelles cette technique est mobilisé
et ça c'est la garantie la plus forte
que l'on puisse donner à l'égard des
citoyens
est ce que vous proposez de mettre en
place est de nature à altérer la portée
de ce principe qui est vraiment la
pierre angulaire du texte parce que nous
ne souhaitons pas qu'il y ait de 10
proportionnalité entre la technique que
l'on utilisait la finalité qu'on vise à
obtenir
et c'est cette proportionnalité qui est
la garantie de la protection des
citoyens et c'est parce que je pense que
c'est cela qui garantit de façon très
significative notre capacité à thann le
but que je ne suis pas favorable à ce
que l'on altère la portée de ce principe
par votre amendement dont je comprends
la bonne intention qui l'inspirent mais
dont je suis convaincu qu'il atteindra 1
but inverse à celui qui se propose
d'atteindre merci monsieur le ministre
je vais mettre voix l'amendement numéro
92 qui a deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour cet amendement qui et contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
un amendement 177 rectifié du
gouvernement présenté par monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'autorisation
de mise en oeuvre d'une technique de
renseignement est délivré sur demande
écrite et motivée du miz de la défense
du midi de l'intérieur où des milices
chargé de l'économie du budget ou des
douanes chaque ministre peut déléguer
cette attribution l'efficacité de la
procédure mise en place par le projet de
loi compte tenu du nombre élevé de
demandes susceptibles d'être sollicités
notamment s'agissant des données de
connexion nécessite d'augmenter le
nombre de personnes à qui chaque
ministre peut déléguer cette attribution
ses délégataires seront habilités secret
défense est placé sous l'autorité
directe du ministre dont ils dépendent
voilà ce que contient cet amendement si
monsieur ministre l'avis de la
commission monsieur le président en
porter
la commission elle-même modifier
l'article 821 4 du texte pour que le
premier ministre détermine lui même le
nombre de personnes qui vont pouvoir à
ses côtés en qualité de collaborateur
direct et c'est très important
prendre sur délégation de sa part les
décisions d'autorisation et le
gouvernement nous propose ici parce
qu'il y à aussi pour le ministre de
l'intérieur et le ministre de la défense
la possibilité de déléguer son
attribution consistant à demander
l'autorisation au premier ministre de
permettre l'utilisation d'une technique
de renseignement et bien que par
harmonisation avec la rédaction que nous
avons adoptée à l'article
821 4 cet article je crois 821 1
comporte la même disposition à savoir
ont peu de ministres peut déléguer cette
attribution individuellement à des
collaborateurs directs habilité au
secret de la défense nationale et à eux
seuls
il s'agit d'éviter que se constitue une
sorte de bureaucratie du droit du
renseignement ou les carrières
s'enchevêtrent où l'on passe des
services qui demande d autorisation à
leur ministre aux conseillers des
ministres qui font transiter la demande
vers matignon aux membres de la
commission des services de la commission
nationale de contrôle et au cabinet du
premier ministre lui-même dans une sorte
d'entre eux soit un complice qui
diminuerait le niveau des garanties
la décision qui est prise par délégation
d'une autorité politique gouvernementale
doit se faire au profit non pas d'une
administration et d'une bureaucratie
mais deux personnes qui permette que
cette responsabilité politique soit
réellement engagés par la décision qui
est prise et qui peut l'être au stade
ultime sous le contrôle du parlement
donc l'avis est favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur dont je
vais pouvoir
l'amendement 177 rectifier le
gouvernement qui a un avis favorable de
la commission qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement est adopté
nous passons un amendement 132 rectifié
qui est présenté par messieurs vous avez
la parole mon chapeau et merci monsieur
le président madame le nom de la
ministre monsieur le ministre l'article
l821 2 énonce la liste des précisions
que doivent comporter les demandes de
mise en oeuvre sur le territoire
national des techniques du recueil du
renseignement
la demande ainsi son renouvellement
doivent préciser notamment là où les
finalités poursuivies pour des raisons
de simplification de la gestion des
services mais aussi pour en faciliter le
contrôle
il est parfaitement envisageable qu'une
seule demande porte
s'agissant d'une ou de plusieurs
personnes sur l'emploi simultanée ou
successifs de plusieurs techniques
en revanche une demande portant
simultanément sur plusieurs finalités
pourrait avoir pour effet de permettre
aux services de se dispenser d'une
motivation se rapportant à des
suspicions des indices précis elle
aurait donc pour effet d'affaiblir par
rapport à la situation actuelle
un contrôle que chacun s'accorde pour
dire qu'il faut le renforcer
il vous est donc proposé d'associer à
chaque demande et donc à chaque demande
de renouvellement
une seule finalité c'est à dire que s'il
ya plusieurs finalités il faut qu'il y
ait plusieurs demandes
ceci afin de faciliter le contrôle et de
renforcer les garanties apportées par le
texte chevaux merci merci mon cher
collègue
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable il à
vis de gouvernement monsieur le ministre
monsieur le sénateur sur une mesure de
renseignement peuvent user de plusieurs
finalités parmi celles prévues par la
loi dès lors que certains sont certaines
sont très voisines et peuvent concerner
la même cible ainsi qu'une même personne
peut être surveillé outils de la
prévention du terrorisme et de la
criminalité organisée et contenu de la
porosité qui existe entre la criminalité
organisée certains activités terroristes
cela est tout à fait possible dans votre
amendement vous le remettez d'ailleurs
pas en cause ce principe et vous
souhaitez seulement qu'il y ait autant
de demande et donc d'autorisation que
deux finalités
d'abord cette exigence conduirait
alourdir de façon considérable activités
de services qui est déjà sous tension
mais aussi l'activité laisse et ses
terres mais aussi l'activité du premier
ministre et de ses services et elle me
paraît tout à fait contre productif en
termes de garantie des droits dès lors
qu'au contraire il est utile que la cnc
terre dispose par une même demande d'une
vision d'ensemble des mesures de
surveillance prises à l'encontre d'une
personne
cette vision globale étant d'ailleurs la
condition du bon exercice du contrôle de
proportionnalité donc pour toutes ces
raisons là je vous propose si vous en
êtes d'accord monsieur le sénateur sur
de retirer votre avis
non monsieur sûr je remercie monsieur le
ministre
dès lors monsieur le ministre que vous
voudriez bien me confirmer que dès lors
qu'il y aura plusieurs finalités chacune
d'entre elles sera justifiée dans la
demande je retirais mon amendement
monsieur le ministre vous avez vous le
précisez à monsieur sur ce sera toute
garantie sur ce point lui en gaz
absolument solennellement devant eux
cette le caractère tout à fait
affirmatif de la déclaration de monsieur
le ministre qui figurera au procès
verbal et qui au compte rendu et qui par
conséquent éclairera nos travaux selon
laquelle nous avons toutes garanties sur
le fait que chaque finalité sera
expliquée et qu'il s'agit de surcroît
d'un engagement solennel
bien sûr je retire cet amendement mon
cher collègue et pouvez vous présenter
l'amendement son 333 et eefje prenant
pour nous important parce que vous savez
que l'assemblée nationale mes chers
collègues a décidé dans le texte qui
nous a été transmis de permettre à deux
membres de la cncd air qui conteste
l'avis émis par le président de la
commission l'un des membres chargés de
le supplée de demander au président de
réunir la commission laquelle devra
alors statuer dans un délai de trois
jours ouvrables suivant l'avis initial
dans ce cas le nouvel avis émis par la
commission remplacerait l'avis initial
alors j'ai bien entendu que notre
rapporteur philippe bas s'était
interrogé sur le sort des renseignements
collectés jusqu'à la formulation d'un
avis différent nous pouvons le rassurer
monsieur le rapporteur philippe bas en
effet il n'existerait pas de difficulté
juridique soit le premier ministre
interrompt le recours aux techniques de
renseignement
dans ce cas les
données recueillies sont détruites soit
l'autorisation est maintenu après avis
défavorable
dans ce cas le projet de loi exige vous
le savez une réponse motivée du premier
ministre et accorde à la commission de
contrôle la faculté de saisir le conseil
d'état
alors vous savez que dans l'ensemble du
texte
et j'en suis particulièrement heureux le
sénat a ajouté des garanties
complémentaires par rapport à ce câble
effet l'assemblée nationale je trouve
monsieur le rapporteur et président de
la commission des lois qu'il serait
dommageable que pour une fois on soit en
deçà de ce qu a voté l'assemblée
nationale nous pensons donc qu'il est
important de maintenir une voie de
recours au sein de la cntr je sais que
c'est très spécifique que c'est
particulier mais chacun voit bien que
nous sommes dans une matière à caractère
exceptionnel
si l'on maintient cette voie de recours
on apporte une garantie supplémentaire
en matière de contrôle tout en
confortant le principe de la
collégialité applicables au sein de la
commission au surplus nous pouvons
relever que la commission des lois n'est
pas revenu sur la possibilité de saisine
du conseil d'état par au moins trois
membres de la cncd r
donc nous pourrions vraiment reprendre
retenir cette position qui a été celle
de l'assemblée nationale merci mon cher
collègue
quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président bas
la commission est tout d'abord remercie
l'un de ses membres les plus éminents le
président fier d'avoir rappelé le sens
de son travail qui en effet constamment
a consisté à renforcer les garanties de
l'égalité et de contrôle de la mise en
oeuvre des techniques de renseignement
c'est bien le cas mais la commission n'a
pas considéré que cet amendement
contribuer réellement à améliorer ces
garanties
parce que cet amendement organise en
quelque sorte le bégaiement de la
procédure de
consultation le bégaiement de la
commission nationale consultative des
techniques de renseignement
elle donne un avis plusieurs de ses
membres regrettent que cet avis ait été
donné dans une forme restreinte et
demandent que la commission se
ressaisisse mais dans notre droit quand
une commission a donné un avis il est
donné et on passe ensuite à l'étape
suivante
or précisément c'est l'étape suivante
qui va offrir les meilleures garanties
et c'est tout le sens du travail que
nous avons fait en commun je dois dire
dans un climat de recherche du plus
large consensus et qui nous a permis de
rendre effectif le contrôle du conseil
d'état qui de notre point de vue ne
l'était pas dans le texte du
gouvernement et ne l'était pas plus dans
le texte adopté par l'assemblée
nationale
mais à partir du moment où il suffit de
trois membres de la commission pour
saisir le conseil d'état
nous avons là la garantie qu'ils nous
manquent qui nous manquait jusqu'à
présent si le bégaiement de la
commission était autorisée par
l'adoption de cet amendement
ce serait une source de désordre puisque
dès l'autorisation dès l'avis donné
l'autorisation peut être délivré la
procédure mise en oeuvre et il faudrait
d'un seul coup dire stop
la commission qui avait pourtant donné
un avis légalement en respectant la
procédure prévue par la loi
on reprend son avis pour en formuler un
nouveau qui d'ailleurs pourra être le
même
et le sera dans un certain nombre de cas
je crois que il ne faut pas rentrer dans
un tel dispositif car il n'apportera pas
ils n'apportent pas en réalité de
garanties supplémentaires
merci monsieur le président quel est
l'avis du gouvernement madame lagarde
échoue président monsieur le premier
ministre président à porter monsieur le
président à porter monsieur le député
président
tueur l'avis du gouvernement est plus
nuancé l'avis du gouvernement plus
nuancée même si j'entends parfaitement
l'argumentaire que vous venez de
présenter monsieur le président
rapporteur la difficulté de cet
argumentaire c'est que il fait la part
entre la fluidité la sécurité de la
décision à l'assemblée nationale le
débat a eu lieu puisque c'est
effectivement sur l'initiative de
l'assemblée nationale que la disposition
qui consistait à permettre que deux
membres de la commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
requièrent la réunion de la sienne ses
terres en formation plénière le
gouvernement avait face à cette
proposition
considéré cet aspect d'une sécurité
supplémentaires par la possibilité
donnée à la scène c'était de se
prononcer en formation restreinte en
formation plénière et par conséquent en
cohérence avec cette disposition le
gouvernement cette fois se remet à la
sagesse de l'assemblée parce que il
entend cette préoccupation des
parlementaires de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat de permettre cette nouvelle
délibération de la cnct
merci d'un ministre monsieur sueur vous
avez la parole sur le président de me
redonner la parole pour explication de
vote je remercie madame le garde des
sceaux pour la l'appel à la sagesse et à
monsieur philippe bas je voulais dire
d'abord mon respect pour les personnes
atteintes de bégaiement parce que c'est
un respect que vous partagez c'est
quelquefois difficile et certains sur
monde cela avec aisance
je voulais ajouter que eux j'ai trouvé
cette comparaison inappropriée
parce que en effet il s'agit de la
possibilité de demander une deuxième
délibération
regardez au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale cela fait partie du dispositif
et lorsque le gouvernement demande une
nouvelle délibération
nul ne dit que le que l'assemblée bégaye
d'autre part il existe en maintes
circonstances une possibilité de recours
on ne dit pas qu'il s'agit de bégayer et
enfin vous voyez bien l'attachement qui
est le nôtre à la seconde lecture
nous sommes très attachés même si que
tous les gouvernements simplifie quelque
peu le processus
personne ne dit qu'il s'agit de
bégaiement donc il s'agit dans un cas
particulier où les questions à traiter
sont d'ordre exceptionnel de donner
cette faculté à deux membres de
solliciter une nouvelle délibération
merci mon cher collègue dont je vais
mettre aux voix l'abandon
monsieur y est vous avez la parole oui
tout d'abord nous avons la commission
des lois restreint nombre de membres de
la commission je pense que c'était
indispensable parce que la commission
pléthorique
c'est certainement pour l'inefficacité
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
si on multiplie le nombre de membres de
toute façon ce sera pas efficace
deuxièmement moi je crains beaucoup que
y est comme ça aux dévôts sein de la
commission des divisions s'il n'y a pas
un climat de confiance et d'études en
commun moi je crains le pire
comparer mon cher collègue le
fonctionnement c'est comme si on disait
aussi bas après tout on connaît ça dans
les juridictions
madame la garde des sceaux il pourrait y
avoir des opinions dissidentes
ça existe dans certaines institutions
pas en france et puis si on n'est pas
d'accord dans les minoritaires mais et
en plus il peut ya les recours y aller'
cours avec trois membres mais moi je
pense que ça suffit si on commence à
dire à chaque fois moi je vous dis ça
sera la zizanie et ça sera
l'inefficacité la plus si on crée ce
climat-là de suspicion en fin de compte
entre les membres de la commission
moi je crains le pire mois je ne voterai
pas cet amendement
merci monsieur le président bas et
ensuite nous allons mettre aux voix est
suspendu ou tout simplement pour dire
très amicalement au président sueur que
l'analogique ils viennent de fer entre
la deuxième délibération d'une assemblée
sur un texte et son amendement ne tient
pas pour une raison très simple c'est
que si un avis à donner lieu à une
autorisation l'autorisation produit des
effets juridiques tandis que si une
première délibération est suivie d'une
autre entre les deux délibérations il
n'y a eu aucun acte créateur du droit et
donc on n'est pas du tout dans la même
situation je voulais juste te dire ça
parce que dans l'élan de l'argumentation
en séance il peut arriver qu'on fasse
des analogies qui emporte la conviction
de collègues alors qu'elle ne serait pas
totalement adapté aux sujets dont nous
discutons et monsieur le président je
mets ou voix l'amendement 103,3 rectifié
qui est un avis défavorable de la
commission et un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté voilà vous venez de suivre une
partie de l'examen du très controversé
article 3 dans le projet de loi
renseignements l'article 3 je vous le
rappel porte sur les techniques de
surveillance à disposition des
renseignements
le sénat a adopté cet article avec des
modifications substantielles comme vous
avez pu le constater je vous le rappelle
le vote solennel sur ce texte aura lieu
mardi prochain mardi 9 juin prochain le
texte fait l'objet d'une procédure
accélérée
il n'y aura donc qu'une seule lecture
dans les deux chambres
vous êtes sûrs voir et revoir cette
séance et toutes les autres sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr et dans
quelques instants retrouvez delphine
girard pour votre journal 24 heures
sénat très bonne soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires